[Music]
this week on forward
this idea of depolarization and not not
realizing that ultimately there isn't
inherent sort of moral value to
polarization which I think is actually
the way I think unfortunately a lot of
Americans have come to think about it my
personal feeling is that we're being set
up in opposition to each other in a way
that pushes any genuine solution Out Of
Reach and probably leads us to National
acrimony or Worse yeah I assure your
concerns Andrew and I think those again
those personal interactions you've had
are probably the only way to actually
begin to change Perceptions in a way
that is useful and authentic and organic
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast author of the politics of
vulnerability and producer of The Secret
Life of Muslims law professor herself
Asma udine welcome Asma thank you Andrew
I'm happy to be here
yeah so we were introduced by Ebu Patel
who's been on the podcast what a great
guy uh it doesn't surprise me that you
and Ebu would have met or worked
together because you're both doing such
awesome work uh how did you guys get
connected wow where does my relationship
with Ebu
um Trace back to I don't remember the
exact Origins but I do remember that
before I ever met him I read his book uh
when his first book which one I mean he
has so many are you just have a story
about like how he came to uh when he was
a Rhodes scholar and he came to found uh
what was then called Interfaith Youth
Corps
um and sort of like his thinking behind
that and that was just I think that I
was probably in college at the time
doing a third major in religious studies
that just sort of came about because I
took too many classes in religion which
I think was one of my early one of my
early not the earliest but certainly one
of my early indicators that religion was
something that I am deeply passionate
about and interested in
so even though I never thought I would
end up in the space professionally I was
studying it and reading other people's
experience working in related fields
um and was just fascinated by it all you
you're a Pakistani American and I grew
up Muslim here in the U.S uh whereabouts
did you grow up so I grew up in Miami
Florida wow yeah a place not normally
associated with Pakistani Muslims
uh I suppose it's not the first thing
that jumps to mind
and then you went to law school at the
University of Chicago is is that when uh
you started heading in this direction
yeah well I mean I think it depends what
the direction is as we're defining it uh
religion for me was again a source of
Fascination on multiple levels the
personal the spiritual the intellectual
uh the communal uh I think ver I mean
very early on like I have memories of uh
being a middle schooler walking around
with books on comparative religion and
trying to generate Interfaith dialogue
among my you know fellow 12 year olds
um and from there kind of going to high
school and working in the space again I
mean this is this was immediately
pre-911
um so I didn't really know what was
gonna come my way but Islam had already
kind of begun to be a contentious Topic
in the news and I just thought it was a
space that I could contribute tribute I
mean again imagining sort of like this
high schooler in Miami uh you're not
gonna have that many people who are able
to speak to this issue personally
um and so I took it upon myself I think
as a lot of Muslims have growing up in
this country to become essentially
spokespersons for our religion and our
religious community and then going to
college kind of doing that third major
essentially by mistake and then um
exploring it further at the law school
uh I think was where I realized that
this goes beyond just sort of like a
kind of more
um personal hobby to something that I
that I'm genuinely interested in
intellectually and could see being a key
part of my career moving forward yeah I
mean you've made it a huge part of your
career you uh with the founding editor
of uh and easing around Muslim life in
America and one reason why I
instinctively admire you is that I went
to law school and uh there were some
people who wanted to do good in law
school but very few did
so the fact that you actually have done
so much positive work uh is really
awesome uh and your book uh the politics
of vulnerability how to heal Muslim
Christian relations in a post-christian
America which uh I I enjoy it I find it
very insightful in large part because my
work now is uh trying to reduce American
polarization and you make numerous
observations of the book about how we
are more polarized at any time uh since
the Civil War which I agree with and
you've been working in these spaces
you've actually walked into rooms and
kind of been like this living emblem of
trying to bridge uh the these divides
yourself
um and you have a number of harrowing
stories in your book about those rooms I
mean I do and I'd be curious to hear
some of your stories
um as well I think it's a topic that
this idea of depolarization and not not
realizing that ultimately there isn't
and inherent sort of moral value to
polarization which I think is actually
the way I think unfortunately a lot of
Americans have come to think about it
um that this isn't yeah polarization is
good and right because we have to oppose
those bad guys
uh you know the bad guys whoever the bad
guys are yeah and defeat being the key
word there like it's just it's not about
any way of of
talking through things or kind of trying
to find compromise Solutions or
Solutions of any sort uh it seems like
the feedback I've gotten from
people who are skeptical about my
arguments is just there is no good there
to be discovered right so I don't know
why you meeting me and keep insisting or
both of us I guess that there is
something uh valuable in the other side
right so the idea is not just that the
other side is wrong but the other side
is fundamentally immoral evil bigoted so
on so forth and if that's the way you're
going to see your opponent then it makes
no sense to try to make peace
um so certainly it creates uncomfortable
encounters
um and situations in which someone like
you or I
um are trying to offer another another
narrative well I've been all over the
country and I know that there's good in
every Community I mean I've been in
rural Iowa uh the Midwest the South New
England uh and then obviously the the
coasts and some of the urban areas and
there are good people certainly of any
party of any faith of any Community I
mean and I'd be hard-pressed to imagine
a town where you couldn't find someone
awesome
you know almost certainly
even if even if that awesome person
might not agree with let's say me on you
know a bunch of things
um but there there is something uh
different in terms of morality or
goodness that than there is in terms of
hey you know which uh Team are you on or
which policy do you subscribe to
that I do even when I was
litigating exclusively not exclusively
in the sense that I was also kind of
touring the nation talking about the
issues that were at the center of many
of the cases that I worked on
um because I've had the benefit also the
fact that a lot of these cases are
things that people know about they kind
of made the headlines people want to
know what's up and so it took me to
places in the United States that I can
assure you I would never have otherwise
traveled to and you know just sort of
one gave me an idea of just how vast
this country is and how completely
different Our Lives can be uh depending
on where we live in the United States
but meeting people that I think are
often depending on where you're living
tend to be characterized in a particular
way often totally and then you meet them
and you're just like wait that's not
that's not true you're you're fine or
you're good you're great yeah yeah and
then I think the the sort of more high
profile contentious version of that is
when you're working on some of these
cases that are uh perceived as being
very your team my team and then you
realize that again just kind of talking
to some of those clients or some of the
people who who uh are supporting those
clients that you're not exactly as the
media if it makes you ought to be you've
taken on the content uh contentious
position in a number of these cases that
everyone remembers like you I I believe
you stood on the side of religious
freedom in uh in the Supreme Court case
uh the Hobby Lobby case yes
um so for a long while I was working at
a law firm that specializes in religious
liberty was like the sole or topic area
of litigation and there have been a
number of cases that the U.S Supreme
Court that the law firm's been involved
in
um but in my experience or starting this
in the space in late 2009 I don't think
I fully kind of faced uh the question of
polarization and like just how angry
religion or traditional religion can
make some people until I worked on that
case so the Hobby Lobby case involves a
fundamentalist Protestant family that
owns it's a closely held company so it's
just a family that owns this uh the
Hobby Lobby craft chain the question
arose in the aftermath of the Affordable
Care Act the specific portion that
required employers to pay for a series
of contraceptive drugs and they were
okay with almost all of those drugs it
was just a couple that they had some
concerns about ones that they thought
essentially were abortivations the
morning after the week after pill and
they said well we don't it's actually
against our religion to have to pay for
these drugs our employees are welcome to
use them but by our paying for them we
essentially become complicit in
something that our religion says is evil
and that that's my version I mean that
that is what the facts are and I'm
explaining it that way and that sounds
not very interesting or polarizing but
as you can imagine Andrew like it just
became something entirely different uh
became a question for example on the war
on women and and conservative religious
men trying to dictate women's sexuality
um so on and so forth
think about the term private citizen
keyword private that's what you want to
be when you go online but unfortunately
not a whole lot we do is kept to
ourselves nowadays it's more like
exposed Who Wants To Be An exposed
citizen not you not me to keep my data
private when I go online I turn to
expressvpn because it's incredibly easy
to use to secure my data and it can do
the same for you it will reroute your
connection and mask your IP address so
basically everyone cannot see what
you're doing and you too can do what you
like in the privacy of your own internet
so if like me you believe that your data
is your business secure yourself with
the number one rated VPN on the market
go to expressvpn.com Yang don't forget
to use my link so you can get three
extra months free that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Yang expressvpn.com Yang to
learn more
foreign
books because you've written
um on the subject multiple times but now
one thing you you pointed out that I did
not know uh was that 70 of American
Muslims voted for George Bush the first
time because back then pre-911 there was
actually something of a common alignment
between religious Muslims and people of
Faith generally they just found that
that uh the Republican party at that
time
um seemed to resonate a bit more
naturally and then in the wake of 9 11
uh them things shifted very much the
other side were now Barack Obama I mean
not shocking I think that was 89 of
Muslims voted for him but
um but similar percentages I think it
was 75 for Hillary Clinton uh and
something similar for John Kerry so
there was this massive
realignment of Muslim voters and one of
the things you point out was that uh
that now Muslim has become kind of part
of this team polarization we're talking
about where instead of it being a people
of Faith it's become part of what you
characterize as a mega identity which I
thought was fascinating yeah so that
idea of Mega identities is something
that's been proposed by a political
scientist uh one political scientist in
particular Liliana Mason came up with a
term and the idea is that now our
political identities are not just a
question of where we stand a particular
policy issue but they've come to
Encompass so many different things and I
think a lot of us especially those kind
of studying polarization are in the
space uh no and have heard of studies
for example that most of the people who
eat sushi or drink Lattes or drive
hybrids which again I think the question
of electric cars is becoming a little
bit more complicated with Elon Musk and
everything going on there but but you
know they tend to be Democrats and those
who go to other types of restaurants and
shop at other types of grocery stores
and live in different parts of the
country or drive Range Rovers are
Republicans
um and so it's just like this extension
of our political identities Beyond
questions that we think of acts as
actually political you know I I took a
test Asma as to whether you're a
Democrat or Republican and some of the
questions were like what is the family
name on Duck Dynasty and you think to
yourself like that actually can tell you
whether uh you know I'm one party or
another but it turns out statistically
it can
right because there's only there's a
particular subset of Americans who are
actually watching that show watching
closely enough to know or on the other
side it would probably be something like
queer queer eye for a straight guy or
something like that yeah and so my
theory kind of thinking about this and
sort of piecing together what I was
observing in my space uh which is
religion and religious liberty is
oh like Muslims have essentially become
one of those traits they've become
traits of the liberal uh Meg identity uh
which is you know a lot of people kind
of respond to that especially
conservatives who are just sort of
thinking you know less politically about
issues that that doesn't make sense
because there's just like all these like
traditional religious beliefs that are
also held by a lot of Muslims and so
it's just like well shouldn't there be
in alignment with uh conservative
Christians and conservative Believers of
other faiths I don't think it's that
simple I think there's a lot of
diversity of beliefs among American
Muslims I think it's changing according
to age groups and other demographics but
I think that there's just like well
that's the way it is but it doesn't make
sense sorry a lot of people you know
have that remark and like well when you
have one side being so explicitly
anti-muslim to the point where they're
supporting a man who wants to ban
Muslims or spy on mosques and create a
Registries and all that it becomes
really hard for the the average Muslim
to be like I'm going to support that
team because clearly that team hates me
um so I think that's that's the starting
point and then of course there's there's
more complexity there so your book talks
uh about the fact that white Evangelical
Christians feel themselves to be
something of an aggrieved group uh
they're diminishing in number they feel
themselves to be diminishing in terms of
cultural importance and then that sense
of a grievement can lead them to feel uh
victimized in a particular way and
marginalized and then they last lash out
or can be
incited or inflamed by ideas that blame
their sense of diminution on another
group and then you make similar cases
about other groups including Muslim
Americans where it's like look there are
very real elements of marginalization
and so the problem is that you have this
tribalism which by the way I thought was
very vulnerable of you to characterize
the politics of vulnerability because
most people on a particular team are not
very apt to characterize the other sides
feelings of marginalization as
legitimate right and that was the key
I sort of Step I was offering in this
book kind of like can we get to the
point or even if because a lot of people
kind of hear evangelicals or other white
conservative Christians kind of make
these claims about being victims in this
country and they the response typically
is you just roll your eyes right like
it's just give me a break you have so
much power
um you're you're you were for a long I
mean for most of American history and it
to some extent even today a majority in
this country how could you ever claim
victimization or minority status sorry
so these groups also claim minority
status based on the on you know
unpopularity of their traditional
beliefs and I think you know my response
to that is just like if you keep taking
that approach all you do is further
exacerbate that sense of victimization
which continues to manifest in this form
of just not even I mean the simplest
like the least worrisome version of it
is that you just don't even acknowledge
the other groups have real Grievances
and I saw that time and again kind of
like a lot of commentary a lot of people
are talking to that there's nothing
really real that's bad that's happening
somewhere Muslims
um yeah that's all just sort of
islamophobia as well you know f-a-u-x
and so it's like well if we can just get
them to start to acknowledge that that's
like the first step and the next step is
to actually understand that there might
be commonalities there there might be
some value in working with the you know
with and among these religious groups
because sometimes the feeling of
vulnerability and grievance is very much
shared
foreign
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
yeah I think it's one of the biggest
forces in American life right now where
uh there are different groups tribalism
is on the rise uh and different people
really feel like they're on the outside
looking in and then other people like
what are you talking about how the heck
could you feel like you're on the
outside looking in
um I'll say I worked with a colleague
who is Muslim
um after 9 11 and he uh came back a day
late from a trip and then sometime that
week he shared with me and uh and
another friend that he'd been detained
at the airport for
like a day I mean something insane uh
and and this guy is as American as the
day is long uh you know he he but he's
he's a Muslim American he had a Muslim
name and hearing about he said at one
point he was like I I thought I was not
going to see my family ever again like
at a certain point I mean they were just
holding him and just like uh uh
interrogating him in a way that seemed
to presume that he was guilty of
terrible things and so I heard this and
I was like I can't believe that happens
to an American and American airport uh
and that and that's real
um uh on the other side of the coin I've
been to rural communities where people
are suffering and people are not
thriving at all and then someone in a
diner would say to me it's like hey why
is it that the media seems to just call
me racist all the time
um and it was in a community where
frankly there was no non-white person
that the person could even have been
racist toward like there there's a you
know like it was like uh
so they said that that person has
problems uh you know like that like they
struck me as relatively objective
um and the the problems were of like a
rural town getting depleted
um so there are different types of real
issues that different groups face and
like my personal feeling is that we're
being set up in opposition to each other
in a way that uh that pushes any genuine
solution Out Of Reach and probably leads
us to uh National acrimony or Worse yeah
I share your concerns Andrew and I think
those again those personal interactions
you've had are probably the only way to
actually begin to change Perceptions in
a way that is
um useful and authentic and organic
how you go about kind of doing that for
every or most Americans I think um
an important question I don't know if
you have some ideas around that I do
smile I'm working on it just like you're
working on it and I'm working in a
particular way so
um so I I'm something of a numbers guy
and my theory of the case is that we are
getting pitted against each other
um by three layers of incentives so
layer number one is that party primaries
disproportionately Empower folks who are
uh at the ideological extremes at the
expense of everyone else so if you have
National approval rating of U.S Congress
at 22 which is where it is
then a re-election rate of incumbents at
94 you think like wait a minute like how
the heck can four out of five of us be
unhappy but everyone keeps their seat
and the reason they keep their seat is
that ninety percent of the districts are
drawn to be either blue or red it's
uncompetitive in the general and so the
only way you can lose your seat is if
you get primaried so your entire
incentive structure is let me avoid
getting primaried who votes in the
primaries the 10 to 12 percent most
extreme so you can take someone in this
version of the Republican party and
they're National in person and they
sound much less rational uh you know
when the the cameras on them
um so number one is try and get rid of
the party primaries which by the way is
doable the the second thing is that
media organizations now are blue team
red team and everyone kind of knows what
team they're on and their business model
now is based upon giving people what
they want and not challenging them and
often inflaming them
um so you want to do something about
that and one of the suggestions I have
is that we should try to resuscitate
local journalism which tended to be less
partisan National networks tend to be
much more ideological and then the third
is social media which is going to kill
us all and what rewards uh folks who are
crazy at every level so so I'm trying to
attack each of those and that that's the
way my brain works
that's what four party's working on you
go for the biggest challenges I can see
um yeah I was gonna say like even when
you were talking about certain news
it's it's might be it might be possible
uh to begin to kind of change the the
team mentality but social media how do
you tackle that one like how do you even
begin to kind of pull people out of
their Echo Chambers
yeah you need to have an algorithm that
rewards thoughtfulness and uh starts to
minimize uh folks who are inflammatory
or insulting or aggressive I mean the
fact is folks just want clicks and
engagement so if being a jackass gets
you fewer clicks then you know you'll
turn it around yeah I mean one of my
challenges working in the space is just
sometimes a sense of fatigue that kind
of sets in
um you know I'll give you an example
just a couple weeks ago I was at and
again I'm dealing with a very small but
still very large piece of uh the pie and
so I go on these talks where you know
there's a diversity in types of
audiences that I address but I was
recently in Cincinnati and Northern
Kentucky addressing a group of
Conservative Catholics it was almost
uniformly white in the crowd
um you know it was like a space where we
were in a chapel we were talking about
um religious groups working together and
then I get a question about which is a
type of question that I essentially
address in my first book that concern
which is like well how can we give
religious freedom and recognize that
there's protection for the religious
rights of Muslims because they're just
going to use it to essentially take over
the country uh what if they grow a
number what if they get too much freedom
and then they essentially end up you
know suppressing all of our rights
um and it was just like okay here we go
again let's let's have this conversation
let's begin to kind of parse like all
the generalizations and
um you know misinformation that kind of
is underlying this question but I I
remember just returning to my hotel room
and just feeling exhausted I just feel
like you know sometimes I wonder why why
do I do this it feels insurmountable
well did you feel like you helped that
day because I'm sure you did
helped because I offered facts and
things you know that
helped to kind of
counter I think some of the assumptions
that were being made uh one being that
there's almost two billion Muslims in
the world and somehow that they're all
the same uh they all come from countries
that authoritarian like there's just no
distinctions that are drawn
um or any sort of complex understanding
of the complexity of politics and how it
intersects with religion and it's not
one of the same and you can have
authoritarian governments that don't
represent a popular will so on so forth
and I don't so I don't know if the
person who asked the question again
these were Anonymous kind of coming up
on note cards like was absorbing any of
that because my experience in other
scenarios is that while it's beneficial
to put that out there and there are
people in the audience who are more
open-minded to begin with and might have
had some sort of
underlying uneasiness my answer helps
them Reach Clarity but I think there's
just a fairly large subset of Americans
who just
think they know what's right and they
already know before I start speaking or
responding to their question that
whatever I say is just a falsehood right
and a part of this has to do with this
perception of Muslims unfortunately as
essentially I and I'm not saying this is
a majority perception but I've heard it
for more than once that for example
white evangelicals have this perception
of Muslims essentially being deceptive
so no matter what you say no matter how
great it sounds No matter how much you
might agree with the words like you
can't really trust it because this
person just has some other agenda
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a pretty short list of things you
can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like
five percent of people do the math for a
hundred night free trial you can sleep
on this thing for three months it will
keep you cool don't just take my word
for it my kids seek out this mattress in
the house it's the number one rated
mattress picked by GQ and Wired Magazine
this mattress will actually make you
happier healthier and more productive
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
now
[Music]
well that's why I've been to Cincinnati
and one of the any number of times and
my organization Venture for America
operates there I believe to this day I
started it in 2011.
um and so I I think that just your being
there actually uh carried a lot of
weight because it's a room that you know
like is fairly uh homogeneous so the
group that isn't you and you're not you
don't live in Cincinnati and so the fact
that you would actually come to
Cincinnati and make what is clearly a
very positive case of Fellowship uh I I
think probably went a longer way than
you realize I had that experience uh
there in a lot of places around the
country where if someone's initially
dubious then things start to click
because of this Universal principle of
reciprocity which is you went to their
Community
you're you know you're not like sitting
in yours and you're not like in your
living room you know you actually went
there I mean like I I think that people
respond to that I agree and I think that
that is the
a real a sort of realization that I had
that again you're not going to be able
to reach everyone
um but there are going to be people that
you can reach and I think in the book
when I sort of wrote the politics of
vulnerability that's those are the
people I'm trying to try to reach right
so the initial question I had to answer
in the book is like who do you think
among the sort of set of white
conservative Christians who have these
very sort of
um oppositional beliefs sometimes
against Islam and Muslims like who do
you think is reachable who do you think
is actually worth reaching right so I
spend some time kind of parsing the
difference between Christian
nationalists for example and white
conservative evangelicals who all the
polyatic points to that group as the
group that has the highest levels of
animosity against American Muslims so I
I actually created I I rely on some
scholarship that creates a scale of
Christian nationalism and sort of like
all the way from the rejecters to the
ambassadors that's what these political
scientists call it
um to people in the middle who just sort
of are like okay I'll kind of go along
with that because I don't know what else
to go along with but I feel
uncomfortable about it
um or like you know these issues I feel
this way but other issues I feel other
ways and you know just sort of begin to
add greatness to that Dynamic you you
said this in your book too it's like
that you're a natural listener you're
always trying to draw out the complexity
and Nuance
um I get the sense have you taken heat
from both sides because I feel like uh
each of them just wants you to kind of
characterize the other team as bad
that's accurate
percent you know I've heard even from
people in my own religious community
that it just doesn't seem
comfortable or seems kind of simplistic
in a way to kind of assume there is
goodness in this other set of people
we need a group of by the way you know
millions of humans but continue yeah
the type of thinking yeah there and we
heard it when Trump was elected right
like they're uniformly racist
um and they you know they only want
what's bad that's why I spend so much
time making a distinction between
Christian nationalists and these others
because yes you can actually make those
claims about people who are Christian
nationalists and those are people that I
don't think I can actually build Bridges
with or even have a conversation a
productive conversation with but I think
it's so important to just say okay you
can't take this entire group of people
and conflate it with the worst of them
and you know like hey does that sound
familiar that people do that to Muslims
all the time right like we're just
inflated with uh the worst of people who
claim to be Muslims and I'm like if you
don't like it when they do it to you you
can't do it to them well the the Real
Enemy here Usman is dehumanization and
unfortunately we're in a time of
dehumanization I think that's from Ebu
actually
that that
Hebrews uh words of wisdom
um but when you were talking about we
saw with Trump voters I was just
reflected on a couple of friends of mine
who are Trump voters uh who are
Christian
excellent people also happen to be
Asian-American in in this case
um and they just thought that Trump uh
was a better reflection of their values
in part because of their faith uh now
I wouldn't characterize them as immoral
racist like you know like they're
they're good people you know like I I
know them quite well
um and that's just the tip of the
iceberg in terms of my own network I
have family members who resemble the
same thing I've got you know like uh
probably dozens or hundreds there were a
lot of people who supported Trump who
supported me during the presidential
um and last I checked you know like I'm
not white you know so so it's so
characterizing a group of tens of
millions of Americans in a particular
way I've always resisted it I sense that
you resisted it too just because if you
sit down with a group of 100 people
you'll probably see vast differences
between them and then if you extrapolate
that to you know a few million it gets
kind of ridiculous to say like oh
they're all this way right I mean so
it's the personal experiences it's the
experiences with these larger crowds but
I think it was also and I kind of talk
about this in the the book like how a
lot of this is also something I draw
from my religious world view they're
just a certain conception of like humans
um as as a starting point as good as as
good is inherently good
um and that diversity was created by God
for a reason right there was a we were
supposed to get to know each other or
we're supposed to be different like
that's part of the plan but the reason
for that is to also to come together in
our diversity and our differences
um but I think it was just like I I sort
of point to that a lot which is why I
Rely uh so much on social science to
kind of like make this argument I'm like
look people who study humans and like
humans meaning All Humans regardless of
skin color like they have noticed
certain things about the way the humans
react
um to identity of group identity in
group identity doesn't necessarily have
to be a bad thing it's just a very human
thing and you can use it to good or bad
ends but it's just what makes us who we
are so let's think through that you know
let's just not assume that just because
a group feels threatened
um that that's necessarily a bad a bad
thing right like so sort of the rise of
populism there's like a scholarship from
across
um you know various parts of the United
of Europe that it was experiencing the
rise of populism and this idea that it's
not that these people are racist I mean
certainly racism is sort of one factor
but it's not the most important factor
it's more just about a sense of have
feeling that there's kind of this attack
on their idea of community or Identity
or values and we can spin that in a very
problematic way but we can also spin
that in a very sort of core human way
laughs
three quarters of Americans wish they
started investing earlier and over
two-thirds of gen's ears feel the same
way you know why it's tough It's because
it's tricky it's daunting it's
intimidating you know who's started an
app to solve that are the founders of
Bloom Bloom app is the award-winning
Financial Services app it's made by
young people for young people I've met
the founders they are great guys who
want to make you or the people in your
life who are young and just starting out
financially literate check it out at
bloomapp.com and there's a special offer
for listeners to this podcast fifteen
dollars in free stock and one month
subscription for free go to bloomapp.com
Yang to sign up today
bloomapp.com Yang why stay in the dark
in terms of financial literacy let's get
educated people bluemap.com yang
[Music]
foreign
yeah you can also throw in the fact that
American children are at this point as
likely to do worse than their parents uh
um as better and that's new in American
life you know that the general standard
of living is trending downwards
um in the way that it is I appreciated
your books Direction in large part
because I also know uh some
weight Evangelical Christians who are
very active with the forward party and
they're deeply moral they're deeply
distressed by what's going on in the
country I haven't sat down with them and
tried to figure out what we disagree on
I'm sure there is stuff we disagree on
but uh but they're like me uh working
really hard to try and keep the country
together
um and emphasize our shared humanness
yeah and I think there's a realization
among probably the people you're working
with and and others that I've worked
with that this is just really bad for
everyone yeah
I mean the thing that you value the most
is being threatened by the state of
polarization right and again the part of
it that I look at against religion and
religious liberty which is something
that's very important to lots of people
and so I kind of started thinking about
that I was like I'm working on this
issue I realize that it's so important
to both sets of groups I'm trying to
bring together so how about I kind of
just sort of explore how this particular
issue can be the thing that kind of
makes it clear to both sides that's
worth working together because if you
don't ultimately both sides all sides
will lose robust religious freedom
protections so that's what I identified
yeah yeah you're saying look religious
freedom is religious freedom and
religious freedom doesn't apply just to
one group you know it applies to any
people of faith and by the way it's a
core tenet of uh of our country so you
commented on sometimes finding it
exhausting being this human
bridge builder which I I I uh appreciate
and understand and one of the reasons
why I'm so excited about the forward
party is I want to give you and others
energy juice like-minded people a tribe
like they just know that there are
millions of Americans who think the
exact same way you do or let's say I do
when I say think the way the same way
you and I do is just that there's a lot
of nuance there's a lot of humanity it's
hard to make me hate any large group
because I just know that group is can is
comprised of millions of people with
very different stories uh and you know
tribalism is baked into human life but
it shouldn't be our defining uh
ingredients particularly in a two-sided
system
yeah I mean I absolutely appreciate that
I mean there's something about just kind
of making it a trend making it cool
um you know I think you might have
experience with this but I certainly get
the sense uh if not told explicitly that
I'm some sort of sellout
um you know to one Community for even
wanting to engage in this work
um and so I think that if this was just
sort of a growing realization that this
isn't as bad as people think that this
might actually be something worth doing
oh yeah I mean I think Ebu said it's
like hey look where where is the fact
that being Muslim is a privilege you
know like that that it's not like that
it's all
um oppressor victim you know that there
are uh because you know I I sense that
when someone considers you a sellout
like it it you know it it doubles down
on this kind of US versus them and you
can't uh try to build Bridges
um which I I think is a path to ruin in
very very bad places uh so you know
they're they're more like us than you
probably experience on a day-to-day
basis or someone let's put it that way
yeah and think also again understanding
the diversity so like I think people in
the Muslim Community there are some
people in the Muslim Community who
absolutely face who are oppressed right
um but I think there is also the
realization that the Muslim Community is
one of the wealthiest right in this
country so what is that experience how
is that different
um and how can we begin to kind of
also see the intersection of of class
and race and education and so on and so
forth and understanding exactly what is
going on yeah yeah just want to solve
problems and uh you know give people a
better life of really of any background
so congratulations uh on this book I
found it to be very nuanced and
sophisticated the politics of
vulnerability uh how to heal Muslim
Christian relations in a post-christian
America so how can people keep up with
you uh support what you're doing well
I'm currently uh visiting law professor
at Catholic University so you can
definitely follow me in terms of my my
work there I also continue to tour the
nation
um doing different speaking engagements
and working on projects right now for a
number of different foundations so if
you're interested you can reach out my
website is
asmauddin.com
and I'm easily reachable through that
website
fantastic this one we'll probably hit
you up we'll invite you to some some
event uh before you know it